miles de polacos cargaron contra la
iglesia católica y el gobierno
ultraconservador de andrei duda al
protestar dentro y fuera de los templos
así como en las calles del país contra
la nueva restricción en el aborto el
supuesto de interrupción del embarazo
por malformación del feto fue declarado
ilegal por el tribunal constitucional
algo que supone la eliminación casi
total de este derecho en el país en este
momento no creo que pase nada pero
enviará una señal fuerte y la próxima
vez les votaremos responsabilizaremos a
los viejos políticos y con suerte los
políticos a cargos se darán cuenta que
han ido demasiado lejos seguiremos
protestando seguiremos luchando y ojalá
se revierta su posición han ido
demasiado lejos y deben saberlo
polonia ya era uno de los países que más
restringía el derecho al aborto en
europa tan sólo estaba permitido en caso
de violación peligro para la madre o
malformación del feto la eliminación de
este último supone que el 97 por ciento
de los abortos que se realizaban pasarán
a ser ilegales
y salidas
son divisibles
se trata de salvar la salud de las
mujeres que si no abortan se verían
afectadas psíquicamente que darán a luz
un bebé que morirá
y eso es un trauma para toda la familia
y para la propia mujer lo que está
pasando en polonia no es sólo la
cuestión del aborto sino la cuestión de
la sumisión de las mujeres
desde 2015 polonia ha sufrido una
regresión en los derechos básicos y
libertades que alarma a la unión europea
el control de los tribunales ha pasado a
depender completamente del partido
gobernante ley injusticia